referring back to the stage play that
you've just written and are now showing
and coming up in March April May and
June
she had the title how long did it take
you to finish well that that particular
play took took a while because I was on
a bunch of assignments of a bunch of TV
movie assignments during the course of
well two actually during that period but
I wrote it over the course of about six
months so every time I had a little
downtime from the films I was writing I
I went back to the play which is kind of
a harder way to do it I mean usually I
try to write work on one thing and just
start go start to finish and then move
on to the next thing so I couldn't focus
a little bit more but in this particular
case I again I started and not quite
knowing where I was going so every time
I came back to it even if a few weeks
had passed or whatever it was like it
was like starting over again but it
actually worked in the plays favorite
because it became this very interesting
kind of the way the way the story kind
of spins out and the way that the
characters stories and the dialogue
spins out it's just it's it's slightly
less linear then then other things that
I've written which I kind of like you
know it's the tie it's all one timeline
but but the convert there's a lot of
conversation and it doesn't it doesn't
all necessarily just follow you know
clink into place which which which I
think will be really interesting to hear
so that was a little bit different but
generally I like writing things you know
pretty much from start to finish
however long it would take but if I had
to compress all the time yeah I would
say over the course of about a month to
write it three weeks maybe you know and
then there's all the rewriting and and
now we're in rehearsals and you know
we're working on the words and tinkering
and you know seeing what things sound
right and what don't and what words we
need a better word for something that
explains things better you know it's
it's the process yeah so someone who's
used to writing in the the typical
screenwriting structured format you know
how would they switch gears a little bit
and maybe there's books you can
recommend on how to do stage plays well
I I basically think you can write a
stage play pretty much you can structure
pretty much the way you structure a film
film is most films are have a classic
structure classic storytelling structure
to them by and large they do and and a
play plays the nice thing about plays is
that that you they can be this big sort
of jumble
of ideas and and timeframes and things
that you know don't have to always be
all that linear and all that structure
however ultimately if you even breakdown
those there is a structure to it
so I think if you go by the classic
storytelling structure you know with the
MIT let's say the midpoint of the movie
is that point of acceleration with is
that new piece of information or that
surprise or something that sends the
story in a whole new direction by the
end of your first act of a two-act play
basically that midpoint is like that oh
my god moment and yeah the stage goes
black and everybody walks out in the
lobby like oh what's gonna happen that's
kind of what you're what you're looking
for you have a low point you know it's
probably the 3/4 point the kind of all
is lost moment you have a a quarter
point let's say where it where might be
what's normally called in a script page
30 or the end of for act 1 but in a play
you have that kind of quarter point
where where the the the action kind of
shifts and they're kind of off on the
journey
you know plays tend to have a lot of
preamble to them a lot of just
conversation and getting to know
characters and and until you sort of get
into the meat of it's you're setting up
the world in a little different way that
then you then you can in in a film so it
can take a little while to get into the
real meat of the story but even then I
think in this play at that quarter point
what would be the middle of the first
act of the play you end up with that
kind of incident that kind of moves
twisted it moves it in that in that
slightly new direction that leads to the
end of the first act with the moment of
acceleration so I think then it's not a
dissimilar structure and I'm so you
frankly I'm so used to writing things in
with so many films in basically classic
structure that it's sort of second
nature in terms of how I'm gonna write a
play but plays do have more freedom you
know generally just like with the
actress that kind of gave you a hug at
the end and and was interested in the
way you approached it and and structure
versus you know what she had been used
to sort of working with what do you want
an audience member to get from one of
your plays aside from showing up oh
that's a great thing yeah people in the
seeds but aside from that when the
curtain goes down and they go come out
and bow what do you want them to
experience i I'd like them to feel that
they
that they spent an hour and a half or
two hours with people that they knew
with people that they could relate to
you know I've written a lot of plays
that are very character oriented very
people-oriented very family family and
relationship comedies and things and you
just want people to to feel like they've
experienced something that they can
really relate to and in this particular
case in April May and June so many
people have gone through that experience
of you know everybody's either a child
or has been a child and or a parent and
often you've lost the parent by the time
you get to the theatre you're probably
of an age where maybe you've lost the
parent or you've lost the grandparent or
you know somebody who has so I think
there's a lot of relatable things and
then the the sibling part of it you know
I want people to say that reminds me of
my my sisters and my brothers and my
cousins or that's just like cousin
so-and-so or whatever whatever I think
there'll be a lot of that kind of
recognition so I want people to be moved
you know by move by the characters that
I've created and the kind of relating to
the whole idea of that yes we don't
always know our parents and our parents
don't always know us and maybe they'll
go home and spend a little time talking
to their parents before it's too late
ask that question tell me about that
thing that I know don't know you know
say to your pet you say to your mother
say to your father if you were to die
tomorrow what would I discover going
through your things that you'd rather
tell me about now so I won't have a lot
of questions you know so I think there's
a lot of food for thought you know that
hopefully out of this play will come and
and generally with plays they just want
people to feel not just that they had a
good time and whatever but they really
got something out of there was an
emotional connection that they got out
of it you know that they can then take
with them and it can resonate
you